squeezed that at the tail end that shouldn't
have materialized from Center Ice nice acceptance
Johnston in the M of the save and he hangs
on As Time expires Jake aringer would have
had him closed down anyway nice dangling by
now 0 for 16 on the power play here at home
right off the draw shot sa pelski fed it
into the goal mouth and springing out with
just chaotic activity at the net front both
hints and pavelski crws in there Robertson
right there as well here schaltz feeding the
slots broken up he's a 75 coyotes win duaine
steals he's in nice move duain to the
forehead just keeping it out Vela sudor
BS it off the boards schz tries to settle
down Johnson in as well Pi up up along the
wall right out by the Stars bin in Under Fire
it's Keller delay shoots scores Layon Keller
gets the first goal of the game it's Arizona who
takes a one- nothing lead to get that one home
at the other end Puck comes off the board Stars
think they're in good stead and ML hkin and had
trouble with a bouncing Puck November after a slow
start to the season shot by Brown bounces off AER
the rebound loose for a moment then aer's got it
and hangs for the whistle and the the coyotes will
pounce they they're they're a pretty aggressive
for checking team and can skate and we've already
seen that obviously was watching that and knowing
it can come back in on you at any time in with
speed as haen hits the brakes F overall pick in
2019 in front for Dumba de left in the opening
period Jacob got your big stop on dumbu Fast
Pace already down to 6 and2 and Counting left
in the opening frame star steel shot pelski and
Vela made the same he's had some in tight stops
on Dallas Peli for Neil's lanquist skates it
into the Zone feeds it for Lindell he shoots he
scores as Lindell late in the first period
oh on the board and the Stars TI it at one
stars in transition very aggressive Neils
lanquist on the boards his D partner comes
down the slot makes himself available one
of the notes I had on elind Del was he's
he's got to stop hitting the glass and
start hitting the net cuz he'll creep
in but he was going for the nether reaches
a lot this time keeps it right on the ice
so he draws one here is the fourth line who
drew one early in the game in Minnesota that
set off all the fireworks here's Robertson in
shot save Dallas reloads hin in hits one timer
[Music] score Ro B hints power play goal for
the Stars they first on home ice this season
and they've got their first lead of the night
all the coaches for the coyotes were staring at
the monitor at their feet it was such a mess
at the net but Fela had an Ting opportunity
to get himself set back up again little stick
language from Meo hin in one time wicked one
from rope hints boy a lot of bodies in front
of that coyote net for their net minder to try
to peer through pavelski down gets himself up
and out of the way did not interfere with the
net minder at 10 seconds left on the five on
three her o hinan for duain flung It Wide hinan
will hold his own only two seconds left on the
two-man Advantage Roberts it delays shoots in
a glove save a Nifty one love that where they
can end the dangerous rotation of a power play
with a kind of an Artful snare on the goal score
that's a difficult save it's a a perfect little
lean forward to get past the block of St and then
he has eyes for that top Corner again it's not a
blocker hug St played keep away using a large
body and then he accelerates cross the Dallas
blue Fe for kuss shovel towards the net deep in
his crease AER holds his ground and able to get
the whistle funnel the puck to the net and it
looked as though AER was prepping himself for
a pass in front as well as handle things on the
short stars can't clear kept in along the wall
coie he'll deliver it to the corner schaltz
and it's pounced on by ottinger and Hawkin
paw comes in and upstairs moer back across
zooker forgot the puck gets it back moer left
wing melli drifts down F across zooker scores
the setup from Matias melli and Jason zooker
has a power play goal the coyotes have tied the
game here in the third period Well their second
unit gets out here and the the little whiff by
zooker initially allowed him to kind of settle
it down the business point of all this though is
a succulent little saucer pass by melli takes it
deep finds a window it it lands perfectly for
zooker to get it off the pass attacking and
trying to create been that kind of night stars
have it in the offensive zone pelski bouncing
in the slot dery goes forward Krauss doesn't have
a lot of real estate turns in and he scores L and
Krauss got to the puck in time used the Long
Reach and then went stick side on AER and the
coyotes have stunned the stars with two goals
here in the third to take the lead respon shift
going and and then ultimately turn it over Just
Bounce one forward to the big lanky power forward
and tinger got in between being aggressive
or laying back and got murdered by that as
cruss caught up to it pulled it around the Poke
check and then flipped it home length either go
or don't and Jake got caught in between on that
one suder duaine Springs it Sean has a step Sean
[Applause] scores Tyler Sean TIG the guts of the
ice Sean took off as soon as duchan had partial
possession to that puck Tyler hit the gas got it
at the Blue Line undressed theot more moves than
a snake falling out of a tree and then tosses
a backand over top vintage San pocket P rims it
around gets through Robertson shot and then off
the post it stayed out with two seconds left and
the horn sounds Dallas had the chance it struck
iron behind Vela Keller hops on it turned it
over hen helped take it away it's knocked off his
stick follow up Sean he's in with duain San with
duain San duchaine score game [Applause] [Music]
over Matt duade the Stars win it in overtime 4
to3 down and then it was just passed to
duy from the right hand side Sean great
temporizing to work around the check and
duchan just barrels to the front of the net
and Tucks it home what a beautiful overtime
Ender perhaps duchaine is the secret sauce
that they needed what a finish for Tyler Sean
and Matt dou Shan that combined for the top